marie-guite dufay l'annoncent en avant
première l'équipementier faurecia va
implanter son centre mondial de
recherches et développement sur les
réservoir à hydrogène dans la région et
plus précisément à bavans près de
montbéliard
un projet qui sera soutenu par la région
à hauteur de 4,9 millions d'euros bavans
était en concurrence avec berlin et
aussi avec grenoble
du fait de la liaison maintenant entre
faurecia et michelin et c'est ici que la
décision est prise c'est ici que se
mettra en place ce centre de r&d avec
l'écosystème extraordinaires que nous
avons notamment ici dans ses locaux avec
l'utbm le fc lab autour de l'hydrogène
une excellente nouvelle pour sébastien
faivre
ce dirigeant d'une start-up belfortaine
s'est spécialisé dans la fabrication de
générateurs d'électricité fonctionnant à
l'hydrogène
pour lui c'est toute la filière qui va
en profiter
ça va donner un dynamisme avec notamment
un accroissement de tout ce qui est
station de distribution et l'ensemble
des équipements nécessaires que ça soit
sur la partie automobile ou sur la
partie stationnaire bâtiment finalement
l'hydrogène c'est un vecteur énergétique
qui peut répondre à ces deux domaines là
si le projet se concrétise rapidement le
nord franche-comté pourrait devenir
l'une des places fortes de l'hydrogène
en france